[Music]
you woke up in academia you were born
into a conundrum
and I don't care how we label it or
lower our anxiety by going like well
it's listen it's not this insider let's
just talk about this shared mystery that
we're soaking in I want to be careful
here what we're talking about depression
because I I had a friend who was very
depressed and I remember talking to him
out of love trying to explain some of
these ideas some of these ways that we
can think and interpret our suffering
and sometimes when someone is suffering
the last thing they want is for you to
go hey there's another way to look at
this
maybe that's later none of this is to be
imposed on anybody and I don't want to
belittle or just say like you know your
brain is that's really it's your
attachment to your desire to not be
depressed it's causing you know none of
that that is not what I'm saying at all
we can give space to someone's
depression we can love them we can on it
we can just eat some noodles
we can watch the movies whatever it is
we can just sit and not talk that's
that's real stuff it's a it's a real I
don't know if you call it a disorder or
disease but it's happening and we don't
need to coach people through with
ideologies right that being said if
you're in a place to talk about this
usually when you're not depressed
I found it helpful to step inside what I
what I call the witness and and we other
traditions call that your soul I believe
science might just call it your the
phenomenon of your base consciousness if
you think about when you were born I
have a baby girl now she's not thinking
and ideas yeah she doesn't know she's
American she doesn't know she lives in
California just like a ladybug doesn't
know it's Italian you know and I mean
it's just awareness so she's just there
and but slowly over time we build up
what young and others called the false
self right so we have the story of who
we are and I'm a man and I'm a comedian
and how much I'm a tall man I have big
teeth and all these things and I like
the first two Batman movies
I don't drink coffee or whatever it is
so you build up this identity and
oftentimes in that identity is where
things like suffering are occurring
sometimes I can't speak for everybody
but I will say that for me when I've
been depressed and I get depressed I I
have irrational bouts of anxiety I have
random like FedEx deliveries of
despondency just like I didn't order
this oh well
keep the PJs on cancel everything you're
doing today it's time to take a sad
shower like that happens to me right so
I'm speaking for me with full respect to
other people's processes and their
experience when I'm depressed if I can
get into that quiet space it's the space
that's noticing the thoughts so if you
think I'm hungry
we always just think that I'm hungry is
the thought and in the in the animal and
then we eat and it goes thank you who's
talking to who really I would say that
the thought is talking to your awareness
your base awareness your witness so
that's what's watching your thoughts and
if you can get into that you see how
impartial and unswayed by your life
circumstance this witness really is it's
it's just there it's neutral it's just
business it's just this and it's just
watching it's compassionate it's
involved its invested but it's not
really as connected and tied to the
events of your life story as you are as
your false self is so when those
depressions happen
I found it helpful and this is something
ROM das taught me is instead of
identifying with the depression and
saying I am depressed although that is
how I might say to somebody what I'm
thinking is there is depression I am
noticing it's gonna make me cry I'm
seeing depression and you can almost
it's it's not denial it's real and it's
valid but it's a little bit you're a
little bit less in the quicksand and you
go wow this is around us he's like I
don't know if people get out of
depressions like this one look at this
one this is too much this is
but who is noticing it and Ramdas asks
is the part of you that's noticing the
depression depressed now I asked my
friend that who was depressed and he
said yes so not everybody is there not
everybody can get there in my experience
later he did by the way we talked about
it later in my experience I I've had
success in getting into the place that
goes there is an impartial part of me
that's witnessing whatever the feeling
is and I can rest in that
Ramdas talks about it being like a
candle that's inside that isn't swayed
or flicker it's by the wind it's not
it's in a quiet place and when you go in
there you don't resist the depression
you give it space you observe it you
don't identify with it you honor it
sometimes you medicate it sometimes you
go to therapy I'm not I'm not saying we
need to sit in the cave and heal
ourselves but I am saying that there is
some relief to be had in not identifying
as I'm I'm this I'm I'm sad I do it all
the time there is sadness
I'm anxious there is anxiety look at
Pete he's anxious there and this is
every there's every great spiritual
mystic through all time they've all been
doing this st. Francis called his body
his corpse usually I drag my corpse
around the corpse wants to eat you know
you mean that's that's I don't like it
because it kind of puts it down but I
just go like I say - Valerie all the
time I go Pete's frustrated you don't
even mean not I'm frustrated this is
real my parents should they should
listen more my dad still wants me to be
a baseball player
look at Pete go oh and then and you're
there and you're just like you're not
being flickered by the wind because
that's always going to be there and you
and and with practice with meditation
with mindfulness and with contemplation
and study literally like reading about
it talking about it like this when we're
in it in real time not not necessarily
later at the beginning it goes like this
you're depressing then later you look
back and go oh I think I was still this
watching me and then with practice when
it's happening you can go this I can
witness this in real
time I can go that's happening it's a
phenomenon it's real it's to be honored
I understand but it's not who I really
am
[Music]